[Music]
the last soviet leader and first
president of russia mikhail gorbachev
lying in state a farewell ceremony in
moscow's house of the unions a venue for
state funerals in the past though this
one without quite the same reverence
attached at least from the current
president vladimir putin's schedule too
busy to make it he paid his respects on
thursday to a man whose legacy and
commitment to freedoms within russia and
peace beyond its borders he has almost
totally undone in a way
this snob
that
uh putin has delivered to the dead
uh man is
is a sort of accolade it's it's showing
that he fears still
the ideas
that gabachov stood for the only foreign
leader in attendance hungary is victor
orban other western nations represented
by their ambassadors a mark of russia's
isolation
a friend to western leaders gorbachev's
commitment to nuclear disarmament and a
reformist agenda brought an end to the
cold war but to the soviet union too
unable to withstand the social currents
he'd unleashed his biggest regret he had
said not finishing perestroika the
economic restructuring he'd set in
motion
and much as many in russia blame
gorbachev today for the collapse of the
soviet union and the chaos which
followed many thousands came to pay
their respects in moscow to a leader who
had offered their country hope for a
better future
thanks to him we had glasnost and paris
we need politicians like him to settle
the situation in the world when it's on
the verge of world war iii
[Music]
it's very symbolic that gorbachev died
now amid an outbreak of barbarity
we're saying goodbye to him but also to
the hope that we can live in a civilized
way in a civilized world in russia
laid to rest as the rain fell not
outside the kremlin's walls like other
soviet leaders but in moscow's
novodevichy cemetery beside his beloved
wife raisa it is what he would have
wanted
dana magnay sky news moscow